time for our draft of the drafts that
that most shaped franchises in good ways
and in bad ways and peter we have an
intriguing trivia question
for you
1964.
has the record for the most hall of
famers selected in one draft class at
11.
one of those hall of famers went in not
as a player but as a coach
1964. who was he
round seven taken by the detroit lions
1964 bill parcells
there you go yeah absolutely right
uh
dwayne you know why i don't know why
that is not question he was playing
parcels dwayne charles parcells yeah he
was picked right next to bob hayes in
that draft
wow before or after him yeah
was he before or was it after i think
hayes was before yeah i forgot yeah
that'd be that'd be far better boy you'd
hate to be the last guy taken before bob
hayes and never play
anyway
you get the first pick drafts that
transformed franchises for good reasons
or for bad reasons what do you got
you know i'm going to start with the
1974 pittsburgh steelers um
it's pretty impossible to think of
drafting four hall of famers
in one draft
and getting three of the hall of famers
after round one
swann
jack lambert stallworth
webster
one draft that was basically
the the start of uh the great great
pittsburgh steelers dynasty now
everybody will say well wait a second
they drafted bradshaw years before yeah
you know you had the quarterback shakily
in place
but what i'm saying is that completed
that gave them
every spot on their roster every needy
spot on their roster got filled right
there and enabled them to win four of
the next six super bowls
an unbelievable draft four hall of
famers in the draft donnie shell who'll
go in later this year undrafted that
season unbelievable performance by the
steelers and kevin colbert the gm of the
team has cited that example getting
ready for this year's draft because back
in 74 there weren't pro day workouts
there weren't private workouts there
weren't 30 players who came in to visit
before the draft they had to rely upon
their evaluation of the players of their
evaluation of the film and they they did
it better than anyone ever did it that
year all right i'm torn between
positivity
and negativity i'm gonna start with
positivity peter and i did a little
research today this is before my time i
wasn't alive yet but the 1958 green bay
packers had one hell of a draft because
they found three hall of famers that
year and jim taylor ray nichky and now
jerry cramer who's made it within the
past year or two
and that laid the foundation for the
team that won pretty much every
championship once vince lombardi got
there and then the first two super bowls
so taylor nichky and kramer all arriving
in 1958 in green bay that's my first
pick
okay so i'm going to give you a negative
right now but it's not going to be one
that you would expect
and it's the 2004
oakland raiders
and i have vivid recollections of this
year in this draft
friday for an hour and a half the day
before the draft kicked off i sat in al
davis's office it's my last lengthy
conversation with al davis we talked
about everything we spent a half hour
talking about women's basketball it was
just a fascinating day
and that week that week
they had had eli manning in their
building
and they liked them and they had also
had a lot of other players through the
draft come through the doors of their
building to check out and look into
so
with larry fitzgerald
phillip rivers and ben roethlisberger on
the board
they picked iowa tackle robert gallery
and robert gallery couldn't play tackle
in the nfl they moved him to guard he
was a decent guard but imagine
you left
two quarterbacks
who are going to play basically
the next 15 16 years for their teams
and what happened to the raiders then
is that for the next six years
they lost double-digit games
and it is all because of a fateful day
in april 2004
when al davis bypassed two quarterbacks
and one of the greatest receivers of all
time
and let me throw the little ps onto that
instead of making it a separate pick it
was three years later the raiders took
jamarcus russell when calvin johnson was
on the board so it just fueled that
slide that continued into the next
decade and ultimately they made it to
the playoffs one time but they still
they still are struggling to get out of
that post super bowl funk from 18 now 19
almost 19 years ago all right next one
for me and i'm gonna stay positive again
i'm going against my nature here but you
know we're looking for drafts where
multiple players would come in and
completely transform a team well
sometimes it's just one player who comes
in and transforms a team for 20 years
how can we forget tom brady the 199th
overall pick in the draft the sixth
round pick we hear that over and over
again this time of year so people will
continue to watch the draft into round
six when nobody cares anymore hey you
never know where the next tom brady is
going to come from well last year hey
gardner minshew who knows sixth round
pick from washington state who's going
to be the starter barring some dramatic
change in jacksonville and 20 years ago
it was tom brady the key ingredient from
a player's standpoint to making the
patriots into perennial contenders a
team that won six super bowls and a
career that very possibly
not even possibly probably would justify
two different busts in the hall of fame
pre-2008
2008 you split his career in half both
are good enough to earn a spot in canton
so all that for a sixth round pick 199
tom brady completely and totally
transforming the patriots
you know mike i'm going to bypass
what i really wanted to do here in a
negative way because i just did the
negative raiders i'm going to bypass
a combo platter of the cleveland browns
with the first picks
in the 1999 and 2000 drafts and taking
tim couch and courtney brown and believe
me i'm not blaming tim couch because tim
couch would have been a good nfl
quarterback i will not call him a bust
he didn't perform well because he got
the living crap beat out of him and you
ask anybody there in 1999 couch was a
really good player who just got beat up
but be that as it may first pick in the
draft two years in a row and neither of
them helped be a winning team
but i am gonna pick a positive one and
that's the 1986 san francisco 49ers
what i found so absolutely amazing about
this draft is that this draft formed the
bedrock
for the second really good run
of the 49ers because think about this
they got
seven
really good starters in that draft all
from the third round and beyond
you know tom rathman tim mckay or john
taylor charles haley fourth round steve
wallace starting left tackle kevin fagan
and don griffin the defensive back
and mike
i did a story on the 86 draft for the
49ers once
and bill walsh what i really loved about
his player analysis before the draft is
that he believed
that if he saw a guy
at a smaller college
make eight or ten really good plays
well when he came up to be coached by
many better coaches
we could coach him to do that every play
and you know who in that draft he was
talking about
charles haley from james madison
and as nutty a career as charles haley
had it still ended up with a gold jacket
in canton and he helped two teams get to
super bowl san francisco and dallas so
kudos to bill walsh for believing that
in the fourth and fifth rounds
you can find guys to be the bedrock
players on a super bowl team
and and nutty is quite the
understatement for charles haley's
career if you read the books and hear
the stories about the way that guy
behaved but a great player a hall of
famer who took a while to get in but
deserves it all right last one for me we
mentioned this earlier in the program
in 2012 washington made that move up
from number six to number two they gave
up the sixth pick two more first
rounders and a second rounder to go get
rg3 and it blew up in their faces he had
that one great year rookie of the year
tore the acl either in the playoff game
or against the ravens in december and
they let him play with the torn acl who
knows and they did get kirk cousins that
year but he's not there anymore he's
getting it done for the vikings so the
one guy they did get out of that draft
they blew it they tagged him twice never
signed into a long-term deal never
properly valued him robert griffin
obviously long gone still in the league
as a backup in baltimore but that draft
you know not not that it made things
dramatically worse for washington
because they weren't all that good
anyway and they did go to the playoffs
that year but man to give up those three
picks that could have formed the
foundation long term for a team that
could have been competitive who knows
that's a lot to give up and not get any
return all right quick break peter had a
rumor mike one quick thing
one quick thing i want to read the book
one day from kyle shanahan
and and what it was like to coach rg3
that first year if he's ever gonna tell
everything he really feels because i'm
not positive what he really feels but
my opinion has always been
that mike and kyle shanahan wanted kirk
cousins that year and the owner wanted
rg3
and you know that is what became of it
it was great for a year and then after
that kind of went kablooey
anyway sorry to interrupt you no and if
they would have gone with cousins
earlier you know me i don't know that
mike would still be coaching in
washington but they would have gone a
lot better kyle might have lasted longer
you're right kyle could be the head
coach there and cousins would be the
quarter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports